John Wick might be known as
the Baba Yaga to his foes,
but did you know that the name has a
deep meaning rooted in Russian folklore?
Not all boogeymen are created equal. While many
action heroes have been revered by the characters
of their fictional realities, few seem to inspire
the kind of dread and awe that Keanu Reeves' John
Wick does. An utter legend of the underworld,
the well-known assassin and hitman came out
of retirement in his original outing and has
been shedding blood relentlessly ever since.
"But, now, yeah, I'm thinking I'm back."
One of the most notable characteristics of
John Wick, however, is his unique nickname.
In the vicious circles that the character
travels through, he is referred to as Baba
Yaga. While many may be unaware of its
origins, particularly in North America,
denizens of Europe will likely be more familiar
with the folklore behind the foreboding name.
A creature of Russian folklore, Baba
Yaga is something of a Slavic boogeyman,
or boogeywoman as the case might be. Like many
societies, the Slavic peoples told tales of a
frightening supernatural force that would come to
punish children if they behaved badly or wandered
off alone. Though most cultures throughout
history have a similar figure, like Spain's
Sack Man or Brazil's Cuca, part of what makes Baba
Yaga so scary is how downright strange she is.
Though John Wick might be terrifying in his
own right, he's got nothing on the bizarre
and nightmarish stories of Baba Yaga. The
witch is said to keep her collection of
human skulls on a fence as a warning to
any unlucky enough to stumble upon her
lair. And if she's looking for you, she has no
shortage of terrifying ways to track you down.
Baba Yaga has a flying kettle that she
can use to stalk her victims from above,
and she is also said to have a flying mortar
that she can pilot with a magical pestle. If
you think that's as weird as it gets, then
hold on to your flying kettles because Baba
Yaga also lives in a hut that can run
around the woods on giant chicken legs.
While that might sound absolutely bonkers,
you have to admit that the prospect of being
chased through the forest by a cottage on
bird legs is pretty frightening. However,
there are less outwardly strange
aspects of Baba Yaga that might
help to explain why John Wick is known
by this name in the criminal underworld.
One thing we all know about John Wick is that
when he's out for blood, a lot of people are
about to die. Being that Baba Yaga is said
to regularly join Death on his travels,
this adds context to why the assassin
has been branded with this moniker.
In fact, the witch's reason
for following Death is so
that she can devour the souls of the newly dead.
"Is that a child?"
"It's just a human child."
Many of us today aren't as worried today about
what happens to us after death. But in the past,
the prospect of not being allowed
to move on to the afterlife was
a very real terror for people of many cultures.
Terms like "the last rites" or a "Christian
burial" are still known to us to this day.
There are similar beliefs from older cultures
that suggest that if a person is not properly
laid to rest, they may wander forever
or even risk damnation. The fact that
Baba Yaga doesn't just arrive with
death but seems to erase you from
existence could add to the reasoning
behind John Wick's nickname as well.
While most tales of Baba Yaga see her as
a mysterious and capricious villain and
a terrifying supernatural force, she is known
to appear in other forms and even help humans
from time to time. However, since Baba Yaga is
said to have two sisters who share her name,
it's possible that it is these versions
of the mythological figure that the more
fortunate characters have
run into in such stories.
Like Loki of Norse mythology, Baba
Yaga can be seen as a friend or a foe,
depending on the circumstances. While
enemies of John Wick might see him as
a dangerous force to be reckoned with, Wick
also has a moral code and is likely to help
someone he cares for or relates to, despite
his knack for kill-or-be-killed brutality.
Bedtime tales of John Wick as the Baba Yaga
could be at an end following "John Wick:
Chapter 4." However, fans can still hold out
hope that his name will continue to haunt
them in more movies like the immortal
folktale figure for which he's named.